If I'm allowed to have a favorite forger, which I know sounds a little bit funny, it would be Eric Hebern, who's really the Prince of Art Forgers. He's the only one of over 60 that I look at in my book, who I think is at the same level as the artist he forged. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. On today's podcast, how the brain tells real from fake, when it comes to fine art and fine wine. We start with Noah Charney, author of the Art of Forgery.
如果允许我有自己最喜欢的造假者——我知道这听起来有点好笑——那一定就是埃里克·赫伯恩（Eric Hebborn），他堪称艺术造假界的王子。在我书中所研究的60多位造假者中，他是唯一一个我认为其水平能够与他所伪造的艺术家相媲美的人。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦（Shankar Vedantam）。在今天的播客中，我们将探讨大脑如何区分真假，特别是在高档艺术品和优质葡萄酒领域。首先我们有请《造假艺术》（The Art of Forgery）的作者诺亚·查尼（Noah Charney）。
We talk about Master Forger, Eric Heber. And his story is one of revenge over monetary gain. That's why he turned to Forgery. He initially had been a failed artist. He couldn't get traction with his own original artworks even though he had some serious talent. And he had been at a flea market and he purchased some drawings that he thought might be of value. He brought them to an art gallery in London and the gallery said, this is pretty good, I'll take it off your hands, not bad. So he sold them and he made a profit so he was quite pleased. But then he came back past the gallery a little bit later and saw that it
我们来聊聊艺术造假大师埃里克·赫伯恩。他的故事与其说是为了金钱，不如说是出于复仇。这就是他走上造假之路的原因。他最初是一个失败的艺术家。尽管他有着不凡的才华，但他的原创作品却始终无人问津。有一次他在跳蚤市场上买了几张他认为可能有价值的画作。他把它们带到伦敦的一家艺术画廊，画廊说：“这还不错，我收下了，挺好的。”于是他卖掉了这些画并赚了一笔，这让他感到非常高兴。但过了一会儿，他又路过这家画廊，却看到
was in the window the very object he had sold for much more than he had paid. And he felt that he had been essentially swindled by the gallery and decided to get revenge. And so when you look at Hebron and his reaction to this gallery, he is outraged that the gallery cheated him and that this gallery is part of the artistablishment that has not taken him seriously, has not given him his due. And he makes this life-changing decision. What was the decision? The decision was to try to make his own drawings in the style of old masters and
正是他卖掉的那件物品被摆在橱窗里，售价比他当初买的时候高得多。他觉得自己基本上被这家画廊给诈骗了，于是决定进行报复。所以，当你了解赫伯恩及其对这家画廊的反应时，你会发现他无比愤怒，因为画廊欺骗了他，而且这家画廊正是那个从未认真对待过他、从未给予他应有认可的艺术建制派的一部分。他做出了一个改变人生命运的决定。什么决定呢？这个决定就是尝试模仿古代大师的风格创作自己的画作，
try to pass them off as originals. And by doing so, he gains a sort of passive-aggressive revenge that is the primary initial motivation for the majority of art foragers in this book. And there are two components to it. On the one hand, if he creates a drawing, and the experts think that it's by a great master, then he can convince himself that he must be as good as the master.
并试图将它们蒙混过关冒充真迹。通过这种方式，他获得了一种被动攻击式的复仇，这也是本书中大多数艺术造假者最初的主要动机。这里面包含两个要素。一方面，如果他创作了一幅画，而专家们认为这是某位伟大大师的作品，那么他就可以借此说服自己：他的水平一定和这位大师不相上下。
But the second part is that if he's able to fool these so-called experts, he demonstrates how foolish they are, and the implication is that they were foolish not to endorse his own original artworks. When Hepburn decided to forge the great masters, he decided to do it in a way that was quite unique. What was that way? The majority of successful art foragers in the 20th century use variations on what I call a Providence trap, and there are four variations on it.
但第二部分是，如果他能够愚弄这些所谓的专家，他就证明了这些专家是多么愚蠢，其潜台词就是：这些专家当初没有认可他自己的原创作品，实在是太蠢了。当赫伯恩决定伪造大师作品时，他决定采取一种非常独特的方式。什么方式呢？20th世纪绝大多数成功的艺术造假者都使用了我称之为“流传有序陷阱”（provenance trap）的变体，而且这种陷阱有四种不同的变体。
But the essential component is it uses Providence or the documented history of an object as a trap to lure the researcher to authenticate the work. Let's be honest, every art historian wants to be Indiana Jones and wants to find lost treasures. And you may or may not know that the majority of works that we know of made by old masters are lost. In some cases, as much as two-thirds of the of of these famous artists of the Renaissance, we know of them through documented references to them, but we don't know where they are.
但其核心要素是，它利用“流传有序”（provenance，即文物的有据可查的历史）作为一个陷阱，来诱使研究人员对作品进行鉴定。说实话，每个艺术史学家都想成为印第安纳·琼斯（Indiana Jones），都想去寻找失落的宝藏。你可能知道，也可能不知道，我们所知道的大多数古代大师的作品其实都是失踪的。在某些情况下，文艺复兴时期这些著名艺术家的作品有多达三分之二是通过文献记载才为人所知的，但我们却不知道它们的下落。
So Providence Trap uses documented history and then creates lost works that match the real documented history. And Eric Hebron is an example of that. He very cleverly created drawings that looked like preparatory sketches for famous paintings. We all know that famous artists throughout history prepared their paintings and sculptures by doing sketches by doing drawings.
因此，“流传有序陷阱”就是利用有据可查的历史，然后虚构出符合真实历史记载的失落作品。埃里克·赫伯恩就是这样一个例子。他非常聪明地创作了一些看起来像是名画准备阶段草图的画作。我们都知道，历史上著名的艺术家在创作绘画和雕塑之前，都会先画草图来做准备。
But it was not until relatively recently that drawings were considered a collectible art form and worth keeping. It's a little bit like blueprints and a building. You keep the building, but you don't necessarily keep the blueprints. Eric Hebern would create what appeared to be these preparatory drawings for works like the one I'm looking at in the book right now, Anthony Van Dyke's, Crowning with Thorns, which is in the Museo del Prado and Madrid. He created what looked like a drawing in preparation for that, and we know logically that Van Dyke made lots of preparatory drawings, but they simply aren't extant anymore.
但直到相对晚近的时期，素描才被视为一种值得收藏且有保存价值的艺术形式。这有点像建筑物的蓝图。你会保留建筑物，但不一定会保留蓝图。埃里克·赫伯恩会创作出一些看似是准备性素描的作品，比如我此刻在书中正在看的这幅——安东尼·范·戴克（Anthony Van Dyck）的《荆棘冠冕》（Crowning with Thorns），现藏于马德里的普拉多博物馆（Museo del Prado）。他创作了一幅看起来像是为该画作做准备的素描，从逻辑上讲，我们知道范·戴克做过很多准备素描，但它们确实已经不复存在了。
I wonder if you could just walk me through these two drawings that I'm looking at in the book here. I'm seeing the original on my left-hand side, and I'm seeing Heberne's preparatory drawing for this work on the right. What am I seeing here in Anthony Van Dyke's crowning with Thorns? In the original painting, which was finished around 1620, is an oil on canvas. It's a substantial size and it shows Christ having the crown of thorns lowered on him as he's bound and he's surrounded by people who would have been his torturers. And he seems resigned to his
我想请你带我仔细看看书中这幅画的两张素描。我左边看到的是原作，右边看到的是赫伯恩为这件作品创作的准备性素描。在这里，安东尼·范·戴克的《荆棘冠冕》中展现的究竟是什么？这幅原作大约完成于1620年，是一幅布面油画。它的尺寸相当大，描绘了基督被戴上荆棘冠冕的情景，他双手被缚，周围围满了折磨他的行刑者。他似乎对自己的
fate. And it's very beautiful. It's very glossy. There's brilliant use of oil paints. You can have an almost sculptural quality to Christ's body. I'm seeing his face, Christ's face turned to the right from our perspective. I'm seeing there's a figure in the foreground in the right hand side of the painting who's reaching out and touching Christ on his left arm. And there's a host of figures in the background who are doing various things. Right, there are a number of figures, there's one, two, three, four, five figures in the background, including people peering in through a graded window in the back to spine, what's happening and Christ has seated quite comfortably facing front out to the viewer. Now, when we turn to the preparatory drawing, the positioning of the figures and the number
命运逆来顺受。画面非常美丽，色泽光亮，油画颜料的运用堪称精妙。基督的身体呈现出一种几乎像雕塑般的质感。我看到了他的脸，从我们的角度来看，基督的脸转向了右侧；我看到画作右侧前景中有一个人物正伸出手触摸基督的左臂；背景中还有一群人在做着各种各样的事情。没错，背景里有许多人物，有一、二、三、四、五个人，其中包括从后面的格栅窗往里窥探、想看看到底发生了什么的人；基督则相当安详地坐着，面向前方，直视着观者。现在，当我们转向这幅准备性素描时，人物的布局和数量
of the figures is different, but this is entirely normal. Artists, when they're coming up with a concept or invention of the artwork, will do various sketches to try to get a composition that they like. And the composition of this preparatory drawing is actually in the shape of an asset, something called Figura Serpentinata, which was described by Michelangelo as the most beautiful form in nature.
都有所不同，但这完全是正常的。艺术家在构思或创作艺术品时，会画各种草图，以求找到他们喜欢的构图。而这幅准备性草图的构图实际上呈S形，也就是所谓的“S形扭曲体”（Figura Serpentinata），米开朗琪罗曾将其描述为自然界中最美的形态。
The flickering of a candle flame is supposed to be the positioning of the bodies that is the most elegant, and that's something that we see here in Eric Heberin's forgery of a vandike drawing. And it's normal to have sketches that look somewhat different from the finished product. In fact, it would be suspicious if there was a drawing that looked exactly like the finished product. But here you have this idea that Christ is leaning far to the side, he's being physically supported by one of his executioners, as another one pushes the crown of thorns more violently onto his head. It's more dynamic, and there's more movement to it, more diagonalsals and it essentially looks like
烛火的闪烁被认为是人体最优雅的姿势，我们在埃里克·赫伯恩对范·戴克素描的造假中也看到了这一点。草图看起来与最终成品有些不同是很正常的。事实上，如果有一张素描看起来与最终成品一模一样，那反而会令人起疑。但在画中，你会发现基督的身体大幅向一旁倾斜，他正被其中一名行刑者勉力支撑着，而另一个人则更加粗暴地将荆棘冠冕按到他头上。这幅画更具动感，有更多的运动感和对角线线条，它基本上看起来像是一个
Initial concept that you decided not to follow through with for this drawing It's very clever because it's not hitting you over the head with the fact that this must be preparatory drawing What I find really really clever about this was that Herb and was leaving me to complete his con and Hebern was leaving me to complete his con, and there's two things that I found really intriguing there from a psychological perspective. One, when Hebern is basically presenting a preparatory drawing that looks actually quite different from the finished drawing, he's allowing the expert to connect the dots. That is psychologically very clever, because he's taking advantage of the fact the expert has vanity and wants to make these connections. And the best con game is where the mark essentially executes the con for you. That's one of the things he was doing.
最初的构思，但在最终的正式画作中你决定不再采用它。这非常巧妙，因为它并没有生硬地向你灌输“这一定是一幅准备性草图”的概念。我觉得最绝妙、最聪明的地方在于，赫伯恩在引导我完成他的骗局，从心理学的角度来看，有两点让我觉得非常入迷。第一，当赫伯恩呈上一张实际上与最终画作大相径庭的准备性草图时，他是在允许专家自己去把这些点连起来。从心理学上讲，这非常高明，因为他利用了专家惯有的虚荣心以及想要建立这种联系的心理。最高明的骗局就是受害者实际上帮你把整个骗局给执行了。这是他所做的事情之一。
But the second thing was, by so doing, he's also demonstrating to himself that the expert really is not an expert. That he's demonstrating for his own psychological satisfaction that this world of the art expert is a sham world. It's true, it's very clever on his part, and the majority of successful fordras use some variation on the theme that you describe. They set a trap without being too specific and allow the experts to dive headfirst into it and enthusiastically authenticate the work because it feels to them like a great discovery
但第二点是，通过这样做，他也在向自己证明：所谓的专家其实根本算不上专家。他通过这种方式来满足自己的心理需求，证明这个艺术专家圈子不过是一场骗局。确实如此，他这一手非常高明，而且大多数成功的造假者都运用了你所描述的这种主题的某种变体。他们设下一个并不那么具体的陷阱，然后让专家们一头扎进去，并满腔热情地对作品进行鉴定，因为对他们来说，这感觉就像是一次重大的发现，
that they are making personally. It feels like a triumph. And once an expert goes out on a limb and says, this is authentic, it is very hard for them to go back on it. So they wind up tangling themselves in this net that's been laid out by the forger. themselves in this net that's been laid out by the forger. What struck me as I was reading this chapter was the extraordinary attention to detail and the effort that Hebern put in to mastering the techniques needed to pass off his works
是他们亲手取得的成就。一旦某个专家公开表态说“这绝对是真迹”，他们就很难再收回这句话了。因此，他们最终会作茧自缚，缠进造假者预先织好的网中。在阅读这一章时，最让我震惊的是赫伯恩对细节的极端关注，以及他为了将自己的作品蒙混过关成为真迹
as real. Well Hebern was particularly meticulous and of all of the foragers I looked at, he was really the one who was the most passion as an art historian and as a researcher and was focused on getting the materials correct whenever he could. Getting the technique right is something that you can do essentially by practice. You can practice over and over again and you could come up with a signature that looks almost identical to mine and if you practice it enough you can do it with a fluidity that looks authentic. Getting the materials correct is much harder and it's more expensive. It is also not strictly necessary because most forgers that I looked at got the style just about right. They had a very
而付出的巨大努力。嗯，赫伯恩极其一丝不苟。在我研究过的所有造假者中，他是作为艺术史学家和研究人员最具激情的一个，只要有可能，他总是致力于还原正确的材料。掌握正确的技法基本上可以通过练习来做到。你可以一遍又一遍地练习，最后甚至能模仿出一个跟我几乎一模一样的签名；如果你练习得足够多，你就能以一种看起来十分逼真的流畅感来完成它。但要做到材料正确就要困难得多，成本也更高。而且严格来说，这并不是必需的，因为我研究过的大多数造假者都能把风格模仿得八九不离十。
clever provenance trap that was the confidence trick that passed off the object and they didn't really need to get the materials correct because it's not normal for objects to be friendsically tested unless some red flag is raised stylistically or in terms of the object's history. Nobody does forensic testing. This is part of a residual gentleman's agreement in the art trade that dates back hundreds of years that if an expert says it's good, then it's good. There really has to be something very wrong for them to forensically test it. Or maybe the experts disagree. Or if the experts disagree, if they can't reach a consensus, then the tiebreaker is broken
他们设计了一个非常巧妙的“流传有序陷阱”作为信任骗局，以此来蒙混过关，他们其实并不需要把材料搞得完全正确，因为除非在风格或历史背景方面出现什么危险信号，否则人们通常不会对艺术品进行法医检测。没有人会去做这种法医检测。这是艺术品交易中流传数百年的某种隐性君主协议的一部分：如果专家说它是真的，那就是真的。除非出现了什么非常严重的问题，他们才会去对它进行法医检测。或者，也许专家们的意见不一致。如果专家意见不一致，无法达成共识，那么决定胜负的最后一步
by scientific testing. These days it doesn't have to be the case. Forensic testing is neither particularly expensive nor is it invasive necessarily into the object. But Hebern took that level of detail because he was a perfectionist because he loved what he was doing. He was very passionate about it. And because I think he wanted to genuinely feel that he was doing exactly what the old
就会交由科学检测来判定。如今情况不一定非得如此。法医检测既不算特别昂贵，也不一定对文物本身具有侵入性。但赫伯恩却追求那种极致的细节，因为他是个完美主义者，因为他热爱自己所做的事。他对这门手艺充满了激情。而且我认为，他是想真切地感受到自己正在做的事情和古代
masters were doing. And he is the only one of all the artists I looked at, all the art forders I looked at, who I think was at a similar level to the people he was forging. When you look at the work that he did where he basically broke down the different colors of the masters were using, how did he actually find this out? I mean, he was spending enormous amounts of time being a scholar, not just being a forger, but being a scholar. He couldn't have done the forgeries
大师们所做的一模一样。在我研究过的所有艺术家、所有艺术造假者中，他是唯一一个我认为其水平能够与他所伪造的人相媲美的人。当你看到他的作品时，他基本上拆解了大师们使用的不同颜色，他是怎么发现这些的呢？我的意思是，他花费了大量的时间去进行学术研究，他不仅仅是一个造假者，更是一个学者。如果他不进行学术研究，他根本不可能完成这些造假。
if he hadn't done the scholarship. He had a bent as a chemist, and he did analyses of the pigments used by different artists. It is so interesting that he spends so much time thinking about his technique, but also thinking about what he needed to do to himself in order to be able to pull off these forgeries. One of the things you talk about in this book is how he achieved this fluidity of line that he was able to forge these things in a way that looked tossed off. What did he do?
他具有化学家的天赋，并对不同艺术家使用的颜料进行了分析。真是有趣，他花了那么多时间去思考自己的技法，同时也思考自己需要对自身做出怎样的调整，才能成功实施这些造假。你在书中谈到的一点是，他是如何实现那种线条的流畅感，从而能够以一种看似漫不经心的方式进行造假。他是怎么做到的呢？
Well, he's a real character, and he volunteered all of his secrets because he was looking for notoriety, and he wrote a book called The Art Forger's Handbook, which incidentally has been found in the studio of many an art forger rested since it came out. And one of his tricks was to get drunk. He would get drunk while he was making the drawings, and it would achieve a certain fluidity of line and body, and the process, he would not overthink things. And when I was giving you the example of if you tried to forge my signature, you wouldn't have the mental or physical capacity if you drink enough to be too painstaking about it. And a painstaking line is a giveaway
嗯，他是个极其有个性的人物，而且他主动坦白了自己的所有秘密，因为他渴望声名狼藉。他写了一本名为《造假者手册》（The Art Forger's Handbook）的书，顺便说一句，这本书自出版以来，在许多落网的艺术造假者的工作室里都能搜到。他的诀窍之一就是喝醉。他在画画时会喝醉，这样能让线条和身体达到某种流畅的状态，在创作过程中，他不会过度思考。正如我刚才给你举的那个例子：如果你试图伪造我的签名，如果你喝得够多，你就会失去那种过度严谨的心理和身体能力，从而不会去精雕细琢。而过于谨小慎微的线条，
to an expert that's something funny is going on. He would do dozens of sketches to prepare the fluidity of line he was after, but then he would start drinking heavily and then do his sketches as well in order to ensure that he wouldn't overthink things. So his forgeries were actually committed while he was on the influence of alcohol? Absolutely, and he volunteers this. He actually has step-by-step recipes for how he made his forgeries of paintings and drawings in his book, and that's one of the ways we can work backwards and see, well, if these were the techniques employed by Hebern,
就会向专家暴露“情况不对劲”的信号。为了掌握他所追求的线条流畅度，他会画几十张草图，然后开始大量酗酒，接着继续画草图，以此来确保自己不会过度思考。所以他的造假行为实际上是在酒精的影响下完成的？千真万确，他自己也大方承认了这一点。他在书中甚至详细列出了制作油画和素描造假的具体步骤和秘方，这也是我们可以通过逆向工程来了解的一种方式：如果这些是赫伯恩采用的技术，
other forders might have used similar techniques. And future forders literally reproduced the recipes that he put into play in his book. I'm really intrigued by the idea that the motivation for so many of these forgers, Hebern included, is not money. So when you think about forgery and the effort and the time it takes to forge a masterpiece, clearly you would think that the financial value, the forger is deriving, it has to be a big part of it. And I'm really intrigued by the idea
那么未来的造假者也可能会使用类似的技术。后来的造假者们甚至直接照搬了他在书中公开的那些秘方。我对这样一个观点非常着迷：包括赫伯恩在内的许多造假者的动机并不是为了钱。所以，当你想到造假以及伪造一件杰作所花费的精力和时间时，你自然会认为经济利益、造假者从中获取的金钱回报一定占据了很大一部分。但我真正感兴趣的是，
that it's really a psychological motivation that comes first. It's true. The reason that many forgers continue into a career of forgery is eventually they realize this is a source of income, but that initial motivation is this passive-aggressive revenge. However, there's a caveat here because the revenge is a private victory until you're caught.
驱动他们的其实首先是一种心理动机。确实如此。许多造假者之所以最终将造假变成了一项长期职业，是因为他们意识到这是一个收入来源，但他们最初的动机其实是这种被动攻击式的复仇。然而，这里有一个前提，那就是在被抓到之前，这种复仇只是一种私底下的胜利。
And a lot of these foragers have either intentionally made a mistake, perhaps subconsciously, in order to get caught, or quite overtly outed themselves, as in the case of Eric Heppard who published a memoir, and a how-to manual for future forgers. The reason is that they have to enjoy this revenge entirely in private until somebody discovers them, but the moment they are discovered, then all of a sudden they're shown as a great artist, and they have publicly shamed the experts who they were out to shame when they set out. So this is the completion, the self-actualization is only when they're caught. A lot of these
而且，许多造假者要么是刻意犯错——也许是下意识地——为了让自己被抓，要么就是极其公开地暴露自己，就像埃里克·赫伯恩那样，他出版了一本回忆录，甚至还为未来的造假者写了一本实操手册。原因在于，在被人发现之前，他们必须独自一人默默享受这种复仇的快感；但一旦被发现，他们就会瞬间被世人视为伟大的艺术家，并公开羞辱了那些他们在动笔时一心想要羞辱的专家。所以，这一切的圆满和自我实现只有在他们被抓时才会达成。许多这样的
foragers actually inserted what one forger by the name of Tom Keating called Time Bombs. And these are intentionally inserted anachronisms that could be used if the forger chooses to announce that the work is a forgery, even if no one would otherwise believe him. What's an example? One of my favorite stories is a German forger named Lothar Malscott, who was a Restorer of medieval frescoes just after the Second World War. And was a restore of medieval frescoes just after the Second World War. And he was commissioned to restore frescoes in a church that had
造假者实际上嵌入了被一位名叫汤姆·基廷（Tom Keating）的造假者称为“定时炸弹”的东西。这些是故意植入的时代错误（anachronisms），如果造假者选择公开承认这件作品是赝品，即使当时没有人相信他，这些也可以作为证据。有什么例子吗？我最喜欢的故事之一是关于一个名叫洛塔尔·马尔斯科特（Lothar Malskat）的德国造假者，他在第二次世界大战刚结束时是一名中世纪湿壁画的修复师。
been damaged by allied bombs. But when he got there, he found that the frescoes were so badly destroyed, there was nothing he could do, and the photographs in the archives didn't show enough to reproduce it. But that didn't stop, and we decided to make his own medieval frescoes. And when they were revealed it was a big national sensation, so much so that the German government
他受委托去修复一座在盟军轰炸中受损的教堂里的湿壁画。但当他到达那里时，他发现这些湿壁画损毁得如此严重，以至于他根本无能为力，而档案馆里的照片也无法提供足够的细节来重现它们。但这并没有难倒他，我们决定创作他自己的中世纪湿壁画。当这些壁画揭幕时，在全国引起了巨大的轰动，以至于德国政府
printed 4 million postage stamps with a detail from the frescoes on it. But he didn't want this private victory, he wanted to get credit for what he had done, and nobody believed him. So he took the very unusual step of suing himself, so that he could have the public forum of a courtroom in which to argue his case that he was the artist of these frescoes. He was both a prosecutor and a defendant. He was.
印制了400万枚印有壁画细节的邮票。但他并不满足于这种私下的胜利，他想要为自己所做的事获得应有的功劳，但没有人相信他。于是他采取了一个非常不寻常的举动——起诉自己，这样他就能在法庭这个公开的论坛上为自己辩护，论证自己才是这些壁画的创作者。他既是原告又是被告。没错。
It's a very weird case in legal history and still nobody believed him and he pointed out two time bombs that he had inserted intentionally in case no one believed him. One was a turkey. Turkeys are indigenous to North America and there would have been no turkeys in 13th century Germany and second was Marlene Dietrich, whose portrait was hidden in the background and she definitely wasn't around in the 13th century So this is so interesting because of course when you think about stories about swashbuckling Robinhoods the Leaving behind a motif in your crime that you rob a bank and you leave behind a white glove, or you rob something else and you leave behind the same white glove,
这是法律史上非常离奇的一个案子，即便如此，当时仍然没有人相信他。于是他指出了他故意埋下的两颗“定时炸弹”，以防万一别人不相信他。其中一颗是一只火鸡。火鸡原产于北美，13世纪的德国根本不可能有火鸡；第二颗是玛丽莲·迪特里希（Marlene Dietrich），她的肖像被隐藏在背景中，而她绝对不可能在13世纪出现。所以这非常有趣，因为每当你想到那些劫富济贫的罗宾汉式的故事时，那种在犯罪现场留下某种标志的行为——比如你抢劫了一家银行却留下了一只白手套，或者你抢了别的东西却留下了同样的白手套——
the desire to leave a stamp on what it is that you have done changes to some ways from the world of just straightforward crime, where you really want to cover your tracks completely to something quite different. One of the issues here and the reason that foragers are quite happy to be caught in the end is that forgers tend to get very low sentences. Some of them don't even go to jail at all. From a public perspective, there is no fear of art forgers. If you go to a cocktail party, and I whisper to you that this intriguing looking gentleman in the corner is a Ponzi Schumer. You would say, oh, I don't want anything to do with him. However, if I say he's an art forger, you'd be intrigued.
你在自己所做的事情上留下印记的这种渴望，在某些方面改变了纯粹犯罪的世界——在纯粹的犯罪中，你真正想要的是彻底抹去自己的行踪——变成了一种完全不同的东西。这里的问题之一，也是造假者最终非常乐意被抓的原因，在于造假者通常只会面临非常轻的刑罚。其中一些人甚至根本不需要坐牢。从公众的角度来看，人们对艺术造假者并没有恐惧感。如果你去参加鸡尾酒会，我悄悄告诉你角落里那个看起来很有吸引力的绅士是个庞氏骗局的骗子，
You'd probably head straight over and start chatting. I would. They're non-threatening. They're not scary. And there's something to admire in them. And they're these wonderful de-kenzian characters who, you have a sense of them more as a prankster than a real criminal. Is it possible, though, that Hebron's desire for revenge and the psychological forces that
你可能会说：“哦，我可不想跟他扯上任何关系。”然而，如果我说他是个艺术造假者，你肯定会立刻产生浓厚的兴趣。你可能会直接走过去跟他聊天。我确实会。他们没有威胁性，并不可怕。在他们身上有一种令人钦佩的特质。他们就像是狄更斯笔下那些奇妙的角色，与其说他们是真正的罪犯，不如说你更觉得他们像是个恶作剧者。然而，有没有可能，赫伯恩对复仇的渴望以及驱动他的心理力量，
were driving him kept him from accomplishing what might have actually been his life's work? It's entirely possible, but on the other hand, I think that he would say that his life's work shifted to being the greatest art forger in history. And I think he could make a good case for that. And he's in good company. There are art forgers in my book who include Michelangelo, Luca Giordano, Mark Antonio Ramondi, very famous Renaissance artists who also dabbled in forgery, and he is up there in terms of his physical ability to reproduce another artist's
反而阻碍了他去完成本来可能成为他毕生杰作的真正成就呢？完全有这种可能。但从另一方面来看，我想他自己会说，他毕生的事业已经转变为成为历史上最伟大的艺术造假者。而且我认为他完全有理由这么说。他也并不孤单。我书中的艺术造假者还包括米开朗琪罗、卢卡·焦尔达诺（Luca Giordano）、马坎托尼奥·雷蒙迪（Marcantonio Raimondi），这些都是非常著名的文艺复兴时期艺术家，他们也涉足过造假。就复制另一位艺术家的
style, the care that he put in both the concept of playing with the artist's existing ovga and reproducing the materials in an accurate way. He is a genius but he's a genius at art forgery and I don't think it panned out as a genius of original artistry. No one, Charlie, I want to thank you for talking with me today. This has been a pleasure. Thanks for having me. Noah Charney is the author of the Art of Forgery, the Minds, Motives and Methods of Master Forgers. Coming up, I explore why we find art forgers so compelling and why we like studies that show that wine connoisseurs don't know what they're talking about. Stanford professor Baba Shiv tells us about an interesting experiment.
风格的身体能力、以及在研究艺术家现有作品全集（ovra）和精准还原材料方面所投入的心血而言，他完全跻身于顶尖行列。他是个天才，但他是个艺术造假的天才，我并不认为他在原创艺术领域取得了天才般的成就。诺亚·查尼，非常感谢你今天接受我的采访。这真是令人愉快的一段对话。谢谢邀请我来。诺亚·查尼是《造假艺术：造假大师的心智、动机与手法》（The Art of Forgery: The Minds, Motives and Methods of Master Forgers）一书的作者。接下来，我将探讨为什么我们觉得艺术造假者如此引人入胜，以及为什么我们喜欢那些证明葡萄酒鉴赏家其实根本不懂他们在说什么的研究。斯坦福大学教授巴巴·希夫（Baba Shiv）将为我们讲述一个有趣的实验。
People always swear that when they taste a high-price wine, the wine actually tastes better, they derive more pleasure from the high-price wine. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I've asked myself why I find the story of Eric Hepburn so compelling. He was a criminal, but I think of him as a Robin Hood type criminal. Part of it is because, as Noah Charnney said, art crime doesn't disturb us. In fact, as Dennis Leary's detective character in the 1999 movie, the Thomas Crown affair says, the stakes for art crime are pretty low, unless you're a member of the 1%.
人们总是言之凿凿地宣称，当他们品尝高价葡萄酒时，酒的味道确实更好，他们从高价酒中获得了更多的愉悦感。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦。我曾问过自己，为什么我觉得埃里克·赫伯恩的故事如此引人入胜。他是个罪犯，但我更倾向于把他看作罗宾汉式的罪犯。部分原因正如诺亚·查尼所说，艺术犯罪并不会让我们感到不安。事实上，正如1999年电影《偷天游戏》（The Thomas Crown Affair）中丹尼斯·利瑞（Denis Leary）饰演的侦探角色所说的那样，艺术犯罪的代价其实很低，除非你是那1%的富豪阶层。
The week before I met you, I nailed two crooked real estate agents, and a guy who was beating his kids to death. So if some Houdini wants to snatch a couple of swirls of paint, that are really only important to some very silly rich people, I don't really give it in. But there's another reason Hebern is a compelling figure. Most of us don't understand the world of art, and we have the vague suspicion that people who claim
就在我见你之前的前一周，我刚抓了两个坑蒙拐骗的房地产经纪人，还有一个把孩子往死里打的家伙。所以，如果某个“胡迪尼”想顺走几抹颜料，而这些颜料实际上只对某些极其愚蠢的富人有意义，我才懒得去管呢。但赫伯恩之所以成为一个引人入胜的人物，还有另一个原因。我们大多数人并不真正懂艺术，我们内心有着一种模糊的怀疑，觉得那些声称自己懂艺术的人其实是在装懂。所以，赫伯恩不仅仅是为了捞一笔快钱。他是在发动一场平民主义的战争。有时，当我听到有人谈论一瓶带有淡淡的咸味生蚝壳气息、并用“蕾丝般细腻的慕斯泡沫”来形容的葡萄酒时，我也会有这种感觉。
to know what they're talking about are faking it. So Hepburn wasn't just making a fast buck. He was waging a populist war. I sometimes feel this way about people who talk about a bottle of wine that has a hint of briny oyster shell, writing the lacy mousse. That's a natural quote from a recent wine review. Psychological studies show that when you pour cheap wine from an expensive bottle, wine officionato say, ah, that wine has flavors of likely toasted brioche, spun honey and glazed
这是最近一篇葡萄酒评论中的原话。心理学研究表明，当你把廉价酒倒入昂贵的酒瓶中时，葡萄酒爱好者们就会品评说：“啊，这款酒带有烤奶油蛋卷、脱水蜂蜜和糖渍杏子的风味。”巴巴·希夫是斯坦福大学的市场营销学教授。他最近邀请了一群葡萄酒鉴赏家进行了一场盲测。他们拒绝出席。他们为什么拒绝来呢？斯坦福大学的。他最近邀请了一群葡萄酒鉴赏家进行盲测。他们拒绝出席。为什么他们拒绝来呢？你有一个自诩为侍酒师、本该是品酒专家的人，而现在如果我邀请他们过来，结果发现他们跟新手毫无区别，那么他们的声誉就会因此受损。
apricot. Baba Shiv is a marketing professor at Stanford. He recently invited wine connoisseurs to a blind taste test. They refused to show up. Why did they refuse to come? for its Stanford. He recently invited wine connoisseurs to a blind taste test. They're refused to show up. Why did they refuse to come? You have someone who is in Abinia, then supposed to be an expert in tasting wine, and now if I invite them over here, and we find out that they're no different than the novices, then they go through reputation in a way.
好吧，这完全印证了我的观点，即这些鉴赏家其实并不是什么真正的专家。但科学却在这个时候介入，打破了这个美好的理论。在巴巴·希夫的葡萄酒实验中发生了一件事，彻底动摇了我原本的平民主义直觉。研究人员让志愿者躺进脑部扫描仪，给他们品尝不同的葡萄酒。这些都是偶尔喝点酒的普通人，并非专家。其中有些售价5美元一瓶的酒被告知是价值45美元的酒；另一些售价90美元一瓶的酒则被告知只值10美元。志愿者们表示，与从所谓的廉价酒瓶中倒出的同款酒相比，从更贵酒瓶中倒出来的酒味道更好。
Okay, so that totally confirms my view that these connoisseurs weren't really experts. But here's where the science gets in the way of a nice theory. Something happened in Babaschiv's wine experiment that shook my popular sensibilities. The researchers put volunteers in a brain scanner, gave them different wines. These were occasional wine drinkers, not experts. Some wines from five dollar bottles were set to be from a $45 bottle. Other wines from a $90 bottle were set to be from a $10 bottle. The volunteers said that wine from the more expensive bottles tasted better compared to the same wine poured from a
好吧，平民主义者得胜一局。这些品酒者被骗了。但复杂的地方就在这里。研究人员检查了志愿者的脑部扫描图像。所以我们基本上发现，大脑中编码快乐的区域——也就是腹内侧前额叶皮层（ventral medial prefrontal cortex），这是大脑中实时编码快乐的区域，在其他研究中也得到了证实——
supposedly cheap bottle. All right, score one for the populace. The wine drinkers were fooled. But here's where it gets complicated. The researchers examined the brain scans of the volunteers. So what we've found essentially is that the area of the brain that codes for pleasure, which is the ventral medial prefrontal cortex, this is the area of the brain that codes for pleasure in real time and has been documented in other studies.
我们基本上发现，当大脑认为自己正在品尝高价酒时，这个编码快乐的区域表现出的活跃度，要比大脑认为自己正在品尝低价酒时高得多。换句话说，志愿者们并不仅仅是因为觉得“自己应该这么说”而说贵瓶里的酒更好喝。志愿者们其实真真切切地体验到了不同的风味，它确实更好喝，因为他们觉得这正是他们理应得出的体验。志愿者们确实体验到了不同的风味。它确实更好喝。
And what we've found essentially was that this area of the brain that codes for pleasure in real time shows greater activation when the brain thinks that is tasting a higher price wine, then when the brain thinks that is tasting a lower price wine. The volunteers in other words weren't merely saying the wine from the expensive bottle tasted better because they thought that's what they were supposed to say. The volunteers actually did experience the wine differently, it tasted better because they thought that's what they were supposed to say. The volunteers actually did experience the wine differently. It tasted better.
如果你对某种事物（比如葡萄酒）能带给你多少快乐抱有某种预期，你的预期实际上就会变成现实。一瓶200美元的葡萄酒和一瓶8.99美元的酒之间的差距，只有一部分在于酒本身。如果你为一瓶酒花更多的钱，从而让你更想把它留到特殊场合、在聚餐时与好友一同分享、或者为了它而精打细算，那么是的，这瓶葡萄酒喝起来确实会更美味。艺术也是完全一样的道理。
If you have expectations about how much pleasure you're going to derive from, let us say, wine, your expectations actually turn into reality. The difference between a $200 bottle of wine and a bottle that costs $8.99 is only partly about the wine. If paying more for a bottle of wine makes you want to save it for a special occasion, share it with good friends over a meal, save for it, then yes, that bottle of wine will taste better. It's exactly the same with art.
造假者向我们展示了专家是可以被愚弄的，但他们也忽略了一个重要的因素。一幅画的价值，其实只有一部分在于画作本身。当你欣赏一幅名作时，你看到的是画布上的颜料，但这并不是你的全部体验。你还会想到莫奈握着画笔的手。
Forger show us that experts can be fooled, but they also miss something important. The value of a painting is only partly about the painting itself. When you look at a masterpiece, you are looking at paint on canvas, but that isn't all you're doing. You're thinking about Monet's hand holding the paintbrush.
你会想到历史，想到时间的流逝。一幅画的意义不仅仅在于画布上呈现了什么，更在于你为它注入了什么。当赫伯恩的准备性素描被证实是赝品时，画作本身并没有改变，但我们心中的某些东西却改变了。这些素描不再让我们联想到历史和时间，而仅仅变得“很巧妙”。它们不再是传世名作。可通过访问 www.hiddenbrain.npr.org 并在主题行中输入“subscribe”来订阅。
You're thinking about history, the passage of time. The meaning of the painting isn't just what's on the canvas, it's what you'll bring to it. When Hebron's preparatory drawings were revealed to be forgeries, the drawings didn't change, but something did change in our mind. Instead of making us think about history and time, the drawings were now merely clever. They stopped being masterpieces. at www.hiddenbrainatnpr.org with the word subscribe in the subject line.
你也可以在当地的公共广播电台收听我的节目。我是香卡·韦丹坦，这里是NPR（美国国家公共广播电台）。
You can also listen to my stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vidantan and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。